okay so welcome everyone to the final
foundational lecture of this year's
offering of six s-191
where we'll be taking kind of a step
back from the architectures and the
algorithms we've been exploring over the
past two days to take a broader
perspective on some of the limitations
of deep learning and a couple of
exciting new subfields that are emerging
within deep learning so before we dive
into that some very important
announcements first and foremost we have
amazing t-shirts for you that have
arrived and we'll be distributing them
today after lecture so we'll have them
arranged sort of in the front by size
and we'd first like to distribute two
for credit registered students we should
have plenty for everyone
but then to registered listeners and
then to all other guests and lesson and
listeners so there should be more than
enough we also have some shirts from
Google as well as some other swag so
it's gonna be really exciting and please
do stick around for that so sort of
where have we been and where are we
going so following this lecture we have
our final lab which is going to be on
reinforcement learning and then tomorrow
we have two extremely exciting guest
lectures from Google and IBM as well as
time for you to work on your final
projects during the lab portion and on
Friday we'll have one final guest
lecture from Nvidia the project pitch
competition as well as the judging and
awards ceremony so I've we've received a
lot of inquiries about the the final
projects and specific logistics so I'd
like to take a few minutes to to recap
that so for those of you who are taking
the course for credit right you have two
options to fulfill your final
requirement the first is a project
proposal and here we're asking you to
really pitch a novel deep learning
architecture idea application and we've
we've gotten a lot of questions about
the size of the groups so groups of one
are welcome but you will not be eligible
to receive a prize if you are a group of
one listeners are welcome to to present
ideas and join groups in order to be
eligible for a prize you must have a
group of two to four people and your
group must include at least one for
credit registered student we're gonna
give you three minutes to do your
pitches and this link there's pretty
detailed instructions for the the
proposal on that link so last year we we
only gave people one minute for their
pitch which was really really short so
by giving you three minutes we're really
hoping that you have spent some time to
think in-depth about your idea how it
could work why it's compelling and we're
going to have a panel of judges
including judges from industry as well
as Alexander myself and and other guest
judges and our prizes are these three
nvidia gpus as well as a set of four
google homes sort of how the the prize
Awards awarding is going to go is that
top three teams will be awarded a GPU
per team and the Google homes will be
distributed within one team so if you
have a team that has four people right
and you're awarded the the Google home
prize everyone will get a Google home if
you have two each of you will get one
and then the remaining two will be
awarded to to the next best team okay so
in terms of actually completing this we
ask that you prepare slides for your for
your pitch on Google slides so on Friday
if you're participating you'll come down
to the front present your pitch to the
rest of the class and to our judges we
ask that you please submit your groups
on by today
tonight at 10 p.m. there's this link
leads to a Google sheet where you can
sign up with your your team members
names and a tentative like title for
your for your project
tomorrow's lab portion will be
completely devoted to in-class work on
the project then we ask that you submit
your slides by midnight Thursday night
so that we have everything ready and in
order for Friday and the link for doing
that is there and finally our our
presentations will be on Friday so as
was discussed in the first lecture the
section second arguably most more boring
option is to write a one-page review of
a recent deep learning paper it can be
either on you know deep learning
fundamentals and theory or an
interesting application of deep learning
to a different domain that you may be
interested in and this would be due
Friday at the beginning of class by
email to - intro to deep learning stuff
mit.edu okay so tomorrow we're going to
have two guest speakers the first is
going to be where we're really really
lucky and privileged to have her
Fernanda Viegas she is an MIT alum and
she's the co-director of Google's people
and artificial intelligence Research Lab
or pair and she's a world-class
specialist on visualization techniques
for machine learning and deep learning
so it should be a really fun interactive
a cool talk and we really hope to see
everyone there the second talk will be
given by Dimitri or dima crota from the
MIT IBM Watson AI lab he's a physicist
by training really exciting and fun guy
and his research focuses on biologically
plausible algorithms for training neural
network so he'll he'll give some insight
onto whether or not back propagation
could actually be biologically plausible
and if not what are some you know
exciting new ideas about how learning
could act
we work in in the neuroscientific sense
I guess then the lab portion is going to
be devoted to work on the final projects
we'll be here the TAS will be here you
can brainstorm with us ask us questions
you know work with your team you get the
point
finally Thursday we'll have our final
guest lecture given by Yann Kouts from
Nvidia who's a leader in computer vision
and then we'll have the project proposal
competition the awards as well as pizza
celebration at the end ok so that is
sort of the administrivia for for today
and ideally the rest of the class so now
let's start with with the technical
content so on day one Alexandre showed
this slide which sort of summarized how
deep learning has revolutionised so many
different research areas from autonomous
vehicles to medicine and healthcare
reinforcement learning generative
modeling robotics and the list goes on
and on and hopefully now through this
series of 5 lectures you have a more
concrete understanding of how and why
deep learning is so well suited for
these kinds of really complex tasks and
how its enabled these advances across a
multitude of disciplines and also you
know so far we've primarily dealt with
these algorithms that take as input some
set of data in the form of signals
sequences images or other sensory data
to directly produce a decision at the as
an output whether that's a prediction or
an action as in the case of
reinforcement learning and we've also
seen ways in which we can go from sort
of from decision to data in the context
of generative modeling and to sample
brand new data from the decision space
in sort of this probabilistic setting
more generally in in all these cases
we've really been dealing with
algorithms that are designed to do that
are optimized to do well on
Ingle tasks right but fail to think like
humans or operate like humans sort of at
a at a higher love order level of
intelligence and to understand this in
more detail we have to go back to a
famous theorem in sort of the theory of
neural networks which was presented in
1989 and generated quite the stir and
this is called the universal
approximation theorem and basically what
it states is that a neural network with
a single hidden layer is sufficient to
approximate any arbitrary function any
continuous function and in this class
you know we've we've mostly been talking
about deep models that use multiple
layers but this theorem you know
completely ignores this and says you
just need one one neural layer and if
you believe that any problem can be
reduced sort of to a set of inputs and
an output this means that there exists a
neural network to solve any problem in
the world right so long as you can
define it using some continuous function
and this may seem like an incredibly
powerful result but if you look closely
right there are two really big caveats
to this first this this theorem makes no
guarantee on the number of hidden units
or the size of the hidden layer that's
going to be required to solve you know
your arbitrary problem and additionally
it leaves open this question of how do
we actually go about finding the weights
to support whatever architecture that
could be used to solve this problem it
just claims that and actually proves
that such an architecture exists but as
we know from gradient descent and this
idea of finding ways and sort of like a
non convex landscape there's no
guarantee that this this process of
learning these weights would be anyway
straightforward right and finally this
theorem doesn't provide any guarantees
that whatever model is that's learned
would generalize well to other tasks
and this theorem is is a perfect example
of sort of the possible effects of
overhype in AI and as a community I
think we're all interested in sort of
the state of deep learning and how we
can use in that's probably a big
motivation of why you're sitting in this
lecture today but I think we we really
need to be extremely careful in terms of
how we market and advertise these
algorithms so while the universal
approximation theorem generated a lot of
excitement when it first came out it
also provided some false hope to the AI
community that neural networks as they
existed dirt could solve any problem in
the world right and this overhype is
extremely dangerous and historically
there have actually been to
quote-unquote AI winters where research
in AI and neural networks specifically
in in the second AI winter came to sort
of a grinding halt and so this is why
you know for the first portion of this
lecture I'd like to focus on some of the
limitations of these algorithms that
we've learned about so far but also to
take it a step further to touch on some
really exciting new research that's
looking to address these problems and
limitations
so first let's let's talk about
limitations of deep learning and one of
my favorite examples of a potential
danger of deep neural networks comes
from this paper from Google Google brain
that was entitled understanding deep
neural networks requires rethinking
generalization and this paper really did
something really simple but very
powerful
they took images from the imagenet
dataset and you know their labels first
four examples are shown here and what
they did is that for every image in
their data set they flipped a die write
a K sided die where K is the number of
possible classes that they were trying
to consider in a classification problem
and they use this result of this die
roll to assign a brand
you randomly sampled label to that image
and this means that you know these new
labels associated with each image were
completely random with respect to what
was actually present in the image and if
you'll notice that these two examples of
dogs ended up in this in this
demonstration that I'm showing being
mapped to different classes altogether
so we're literally trying to randomize
our labels entirely then what they did
was that they tried to fit a deep neural
network model to the sampled image net
data ranging from either the the
untouched original data with the
original labels to data that they had
reassigned the labels using this
completely random sampling approach and
then they tested the accuracy of their
model on a test data set and as you may
expect the accuracy of their models
progressively decreased as the
randomness in the training data set
increased right but what was really
interesting was when they tried was what
happened when they looked at what
happened in the training data set and
this is what they found that no matter
how much they randomized the labels the
model was able to get 100% accuracy on
the training set right because in
training you know you're doing input
label you know both right and this is a
really powerful example because it shows
once again in a similar way as the
universal approximation theorem that
deep neural Nets can perfectly fit to
any function even if that function sort
of is based on entirely random labels
and to drive this point home we can
understand neural networks simply as
functional approximator x' and only
universal function approximation theorem
States is that neural networks are
really really good at doing this so
suppose you have this you know the set
of training data
we can learn you we can use a neural
network to learn a maximum likelihood
estimate of this training data and if we
were to give the model a new data point
shown here in this purple arrow we can
use it to predict what the maximum
likelihood estimate for that data point
is going to be but if we extend the axis
a bit left and right outside of the
space of the training data that the
network has seen what happens right
there are no guarantees on what the
training data will look like outside
these bounds and this is a huge
limitation that exists in modern deep
neural networks and and in deep learning
generally and so you know if you look
here outside of these bounds that the
network has been trained on we can't
really know what our function looks like
if the network has never seen data from
those pieces before right so it's not
going to do very well and this notion
leaves really nicely into this idea of
what's known as adversarial attacks on
neural networks and the idea here is to
take some example for example this this
image of what you can see is a temple
which a standard CNN trained on imagenet
let's say can classify as a temple with
you know 97 percent probability and then
we can apply some perturbation to that
image to generate what we call an
adversarial example which to us looks
completely similar to the original image
right but if we were now to feed this
adversarial example through that same
CNN we can no longer recognize it as a
temple you know and instead we predict
okay this is an image of an ostrich
right that makes no sense right so
what's going on what is it about these
perturbations and how are we generating
them that we're able to fool the network
in in this way so remember that normally
during training when we train our
network using gradient descent
we have some like objective loss
function J right that we're trying to
optimize given a set of weights theta
input data X and some output label Y and
what we're asking is how does a small
shift in the weights change our loss
specifically how can we change our
weights theta in some way to minimize
this loss and when we train our networks
to you know optimize this set of weights
we're using a fixed input X and a fixed
label Y and we're again reiterating
trying to update our weights to minimize
that loss with adversarial attacks we're
asking a different problem how can we
modify our input our input for example
an image our input X in order to now
increase the error in our networks
prediction so we're trying to optimize
over the input X right to perturb it in
some way given a fixed set of weights
theta and a fixed output Y and instead
of minimizing the loss we're now trying
to increase the loss to try to fool our
network into making incorrect
predictions and an extension of this
idea was recently presented by a group
of students here at MIT and they devised
an algorithm for synthesizing a set of
examples that would be adversarial over
a diverse set of transformations like
rotations or color changes and so the
first thing that they demonstrated was
that they were able to generate 2d
images that were robust to noise
transformations distortions other
transformations but what was really
really cool
was that they actually showed that they
could extend this idea to 3d objects and
they actually used 3d printing to create
actual physical adversarial objects and
this was the first demonstration of
Rosario examples that exist in the
physical world so what they did in in
this result shown here is that they 3d
printed a set of turtles that were
designed to be adversarial to a you know
a given network and took images of those
of those turtles and fed them in through
the network and in the majority of cases
right the network classifies these 3d
turtles as rifles right and these these
objects are designed to be adversarial
they're designed to fool the network so
this is pretty scary right and you know
it opens a whole Pandora's box of how
can we trick networks and and has some
pretty severe implications for things
like security and so these are just a
couple of limitations that of neural
networks that I've highlighted here you
know as we've sort of touched on
throughout this course they're very data
hungry it's computationally intensive to
train them they can be fooled by
adversarial examples they can be subject
to algorithmic bias they're relatively
poor at representing uncertainty then a
big point is this this question of
interpretability right are known
networks just black boxes that you can't
peer into and sort of in the ml and AI
community people tend to fall you know
in sort of two camps one camp saying
interpret interpret ability of neural
networks matters a lot it's something
that we should devote a lot of energy
and thought into and others that very
strongly argue that oh no we should not
really concern ourselves with
interpretability what's more important
is you know generating these
architectures that perform really really
well on a task of interest and in going
from limitations to sort of new
frontiers in emerging areas in deep
learning research I like to focus on
these two sort of
of points highlighted here the first is
the notion of understanding uncertainty
and the second is ways in which we can
move past building models that are
optimized for a single task to actually
learning how to build a model capable of
solving not one but many different
problems so the first sort of new
frontier is this field called Bayesian
deep learning and so if we consider
again right the very simple problem of
image classification what we've learned
so far is has been about modeling
probabilities over a fixed number of
classes so if if we are to train a model
to predict you know dogs versus cats we
output some probability that an input
image is either a dog or a cat but I'd
like to draw a distinction between a
probability and this notion of
uncertainty or confidence so if we were
to feed in in the image of a horse into
this network for example we would still
output a probability of being dog or cat
because right probabilities need to sum
to one but the model may even even if
it's more saying that it's more likely
that this image of is of a horse it may
be more uncertain in terms of you know
its confidence in that prediction and
there's this whole field of Bayesian
deep learning that looks at modeling and
understanding uncertainty in deep neural
networks and sort of this gets into a
lot of of statistics but the key idea is
that Bayesian neural networks are trying
to rather than learn a set of weights
they're trying to learn a distribution
over the possible weights right given
some input data X and some output labels
Y and to actually parameterize this
problem they use Bayes rule which is a
fundamental you know law from from
probability theory
but in practice this what's called this
posterior distribution of the likelihood
the probe a set of weights given input
and output is computationally
intractable and so instead of we can't
learn this distribution directly so what
we can do is find ways to approximate
this posterior distribution through
different types of sampling operations
and one example of such a sampling
approach is to use the principle of
dropout which was introduced in the
first lecture to actually obtain an
estimate of the network's uncertainty so
if we look at what this may look like
for a network that's composed of
convolutional layers consisting of like
two dimensional feature Maps what how we
can use dropout to SMA uncertainty by
performing stochastic passes through the
network and each time we make a pass
through the network we sample each of
these sets of weights right these filter
maps according to some drop out mask
that these are either zeros or ones
meaning will will keep these weights
highlighted in blue and will discard
these weights
highlight highlighted and white to
generate this stochastic sample of our
original filters and from this these
passes what we can actually obtain is an
estimate of sort of the expected value
of the output labels given the input the
mean as well as this variance term which
provides an uncertainty estimate and
this is useful in understanding the
uncertainty of the model in making a
prediction and one application of this
type of approach is shown here in the
context of depth estimation so given
some input image we train a network to
predict the depth of the pixels present
in that image
we also asked it okay give us an
estimate of your uncertainty in making
that prediction and we when we visualize
that what you can see is that the model
is more uncertain in this sort of edge
here which makes sense if you look back
at this original input that the edge is
sort of at this point where those two
cars are overlapping and so you can
imagine that the model may have more
difficulty in estimating the pixels that
line that edge the depth of the pixels
that line that edge furthermore if you
remember from from yesterday's lecture I
showed this video which is worked from
the same group at Cambridge where they
trained a convolutional base
convolutional neural network based
architecture on three tasks
simultaneously semantic segmentation
depth estimation and instant
segmentation and what we really focused
on yesterday was how this segmentation
result was much crisper and cleaner from
there this group's previous result from
one year prior but what we didn't talk
about was how they're actually achieving
this improvement and what they're doing
is they're using uncertainty by training
their network on these three different
tasks simultaneously what they're able
to achieve is to use the uncertainty
estimates from two of two tasks to
improve the accuracy of the third task
and this is used to regularize the the
network and improve its generalization
in one domain such as segmentation and
this is just another example of their
results and as you can see right each of
these semantic segmentation instant
segmentation and depth
estimation seemed pretty crisp and clean
when compared to the input image so the
second exciting area of new research
that I'd like to highlight is this idea
of
learning to learn and to understand why
this may be useful and why you may want
to build out algorithms that can learn
to learn right well first like to
reiterate that most most neural networks
today are optimized for a single task
and as models get more and more complex
you know they increasingly require
expert knowledge in terms of engineering
them and building them and deploying
them and hopefully you've gotten a taste
of that knowledge through this course so
this can be kind of a bottleneck right
because you know there are so many
different settings where deep learning
may be useful but only so many deep
learning researchers and engineers right
so why can't we build a learning
algorithm that actually learns which
model is most well suited for an
arbitrary set of data and an arbitrary
task and Google asked this question a
few years ago and it turns out that we
can do this and this is the idea behind
this this this concept of Auto ml which
stands for sort of automatic machine
learning automatically learning how to
create new machine learning models for a
particular problem and in the original
auto ml which was proposed by Google
uses a reinforcement learning framework
and how it works is is the following
they have sort of this like agent
environment structure that Alexander
introduced where they have a first
Network the controller which in this
case is a RNN that proposes a child
model architecture right in terms of the
parameters of that model which can then
be trained and evaluated for its
performance on a particular task and
feedback on how well that child model
does
you know your tasks of interest is then
used to inform the controller on how to
improve its proposals for the next round
in terms of okay what is the updated
child network that I'm going to propose
and this process is repeated thousands
of times you know iteratively generating
new architectures testing them and
giving that feedback back to the
controller to learn from and eventually
the controller is going to learn to
assign high probability to sort of areas
of the architecture space that achieve
better accuracy on that desired task and
low probability to those architectures
that don't perform well so how does this
agent work as I mentioned it's an RNN
controller that sort of at the macro
scale considers different layers in the
proposed generated network and at the
internal level of each candidate layer
it predicts different what are known as
hyper parameters that define the
architecture of that layer so for
example if we're trying to generate a
child CNN we may want to predict you
know the number of different filters of
a layer the the dimensionality of those
filters the destryed that we're going to
you know slide our filter patch over
during the convolution operation all
parameters associated with convolutional
layers so then if we consider the the
other network in this picture the child
network what is it what is it doing to
to reiterate this is a network that's
generated by another neural network
that's why it's called the child right
and what we can do is we can take this
this child network that's sampled from
the RNN train it on a desire task right
with the desired data set and evaluate
its accuracy and after we do this we can
then go back to our RNN controller
update it right based on how the child
met
work performed after training and now
the RNN parent can learn to create an
even better child model right so this is
a really powerful idea and what does it
mean for us in practice well Google has
now put the service on the cloud Google
being Google right so that you can go in
provide the auto Amell system a data set
and a set of metrics that you wanted to
optimize over and they will use parent
RNN controllers to generate a candidate
child Network that's designed to train
optimally on your data set for your task
right and this end result is this new
child network that it gives back to you
spawned from this rnm controller which
you can then go and deploy on your data
set right this is a pretty big deal
right and it sort of gets that sort of
this deeper question right they've
demonstrated that we can create these AI
systems that can generate new AI
specifically designed to solve Mazar
tasks right and this significantly
reduces sort of the difficulties that
machine learning engineers face in terms
of optimizing a network architecture for
for a different task right and this sort
of gets at the heart of the question
that Alexander proposed at the beginning
of this course right this notion of
generalized artificial intelligence and
we spoke about a bit about what it means
to be intelligent right loosely speaking
the sense of taking in information using
it to inform a future decision and as
humans our learning pipeline is not
restricted to solving only specific
defined tasks how we learn one task can
impact you know what we do on something
something completely unrelated
completely separate right and in order
to reach sort of that same level with AI
we really need to build systems that can
not only
learn single tasks but can improve their
own learning and their reasoning so as
to be able to generalize well two sets
of related and dependent tasks so I'll
leave you with this thought and I
encourage you to to continue to discuss
and think about these ideas amongst
yourselves internally through
introspection and also we're happy to
chat and I think I can speak for the TAS
in saying that they're happy to chat as
well so that concludes you know the
series of lectures from Alexander and I
and we'll have our three guest lecturers
over the next couple of days and then
we'll have the final lab on
reinforcement learning thank you
[Applause]